And as walked,
oh we walked probably a mile or so
we passed on our right hand side
these huge big camps
and they were surrounded by barbed wire.
But real big, efficient wires.
And between the two wires,
there was a huge, big ditch.
And the outside wire was electrified.
And there was a constant humming from it.
That power was so strong,
that you could smell it.
It had a scorching smell
and every so often,
there were lookout towers where an SS was standing
with guards, with a machine gun.
Just in case somebody goes to the wire,
because if you went near that wire,
half a yard
you were just sucked in
- you were electrocuted.
Each of these sort of 'better' groups were sort of
identifiable in one way or another.
There was a gypsy camp
and a Czech camp and so on.
Dogs in between and watch towers
with machine guns trained on us
so there wasn't really any escape from there.
If the guard (?) didn't get you, the dogs did,
if the dogs didn't - then the watch tower.
A number of people had, so to say, escaped.
They walked straight into the electric barbed wire.
It was an escape
- of suicide.
And some people had done that.
And a horrible smell was all over the camp
- terrible.
The time I spent in Ausschwitz and Birkenau
That was there, continuously,
24 hours a day.
The other people, around 150 of them,stood outside.
The two SS men still stood in front of the gate.
And as I walked in the church I- my thoughts were:
Elderly people, children, and so on.
The omen was not very good,
because I've seen what Germans do with people like that.
And then I thought to myself, whatever happens
to my mother and brother and sister, I'm with a family.
And it was very traumatic for me
Because I didn't want to be parted from
my mother and my brothers and sisters
And then we were marched off
and that's the last time I'd see-
my mother and brothers and sister.
They decided to liquidate the Ghetto.
They told us to assemble in the square
and they marched us to the church.
It was a fairly small church and they pushed in
4000 people at that church, without water,
without any food, without any toilet facilities.
Imagine 4000 People in a place
without any toilet facilities.
They told us to come out from the church
and there were two SS officers
And they look you over and asked you your profession.
I told them I was a tailor.
I couldn't thread a needle,
but I thought: You know, if I can do something,
They'll take me.
They told me to go with my mother,
and our family, back into the church.
Anyway, it was a very hot day,
I wanted to go for some water, to the gate.
And when I did, the SS men shouted at me, the officer:
'What's your profession?'
I told him, I was a tailor, once again, a tailor.
He told me to run now, join the 150 people.
And we were taken to Lodz Ghetto.
And all the 3000 - how many? - were taking to Chelmno.
And they were gassed.
And then burried in mass graves.